Freak bitches,
North Korea has a constitution which is for display purposes only,
but what really governs the country is the 10 commandments of Kim Il Sung,
and the 10th commandment is,
I forgot what it is,
something there.
It's the revolution shall be continued through the generations until it's
completed.
Which means only a descendant of Kim Il Sung can be the leader.
So Kim Jong,
Il had three sons.
The middle one is a sissy,
so he doesn't count.
He's a sissy.
Yeah,
they said he's too much like a girl,
like that's all we know about him.
And he's a big Eric Clapton for certain all.
Like this guy,
pictures of this guy.
There's some online.
You sitting there with his shoes off.
So the eldest son was Kim Jong Nam and the youngest was Kim Jong,
Il and Kim Jong Nam wanted to liberalize Kim Jong.
Il Said No.
So if Kim Jong UN is going to be replaced,
the only one who could have replaced him was his older brother Kim Jong Nam.
So if he's killed,
that's an insurance policy.
Oh.
So he killed him just to make sure that he wasn't overthrown.
And he killed his sons to it.
Right now he killed his.
His,
his aunt's husband.
Oh,
Jesus.
Yeah.
But she drove his,
her daughter to suicide.
So there it's game of thrones,
inhuman six,
six,
six stuff.
Wow.
And they boast about.
I mean,
when I was doing my research for the book,
they don't hide.
They boast about all the stick shit they do.
Like North Korea was recently criticized by the UN for having concentration
camps and they literally said,
we don't use that term so we don't have any.
That was their response.
What are you going to do about it?
That's how I described the for the first and only time I ever smoked gust.
Oh Jesus.
You did that while I hung out with,
when I was one of the neighborhoods I moved into doing this.
Is there a fucking gateway drug to dust and tell you as it's called Solos?
Did they go right from Diet Pepsi to dust?
I don't know.
Here's the.
Here's my story is I moved onto this street called independence avenue in in the
valley.
It's like West valley kind of Desoto Sherman way.
And it was heavily Latino neighborhood and like we moved in and it was cool.
I mean,
like I lived at,
I came friends with a lot of people,
but like,
um,
I went from like the end of elementary school into junior high,
right in that era.
So like once we hit the junior high,
it's like a lot of the Mexican kids I was hanging out with,
started hanging out with you a little bit older Mexican kids and a lot of them
were dealing in like kind of gang life over there.
Um,
uh,
it's just part of the way they get done.
And so.
And a lot of them like to fucking do dips,
which is like a fucking sherm cigarette dipped into my fucking angel angel dust
sounds.
So healthy choice dudes out.
It's how I wound up with this,
this little tattoo right here.
First Tattoo I ever had in my life.
This little three dots.
Normally it's supposed to be up here,
but I wasn't in a gang.
Oh.
So it's like,
for some reason I was so fucked up.
This is what wound up.
I mean this,
this represents what they called me,
veto loca.
It's like little three dots here,
but it's like that happened because I smoke because these dudes pass me the
sherm.
I didn't really know what I was when I was like this bang and the literally the
way you just described that time traveling,
it was like I felt like if I thought of something to do by the time I was
finished with the thought of thinking to do it,
I had already done it.
I'm going to call my mom goodbye mom.
That kind of thing.
It was like fucking nuts.
I fucking never experienced anything like that.
I was terrified.
Terrified.
I didn't know what the fuck's going on.
You know?
It was almost like,
you know what I mean?
They gave me a lot of feelings is if you remember the first Friday movie when
Chris Tucker reflects on like somebody snuck him a little piece of dust and he
fucking.
It's.
I didn't lose my mind naked all that shit.
But I feel like I was the butt of a joke that night.
Like like somebody gave me some dust,
I was like,
let's watch fucking the white boy fucking trip on dust on it,
but it made for a good story on Joe Rogan,
so no,
I'm.
You didn't have to sit there and say,
well,
a hundred years from now they're going to lose people looking at our level of
knowledge and they'll be saying the same exact thing.
What do you think would be the Big One?
Would you think it would be antidepressants?
Do you think it would be painkillers that they're handing out?
What do you think would be the big one that people would be freaking out about
today?
I think about what we think what we're doing now.
That's.
I think it's overwhelmingly good to be my God that that quaint,
medieval destructive belief they held onto them about human agency and freewill.
Whoa.
They punished people who had brains that couldn't regulate their own behavior.
They punished people who because of toxin exposure or stress during adolescence,
wound up with brains that couldn't control this or that a particular junctures
and they used words like justice back then.
Wow.
I can't believe the stuff they did,
it was practically like gangs of Gordy peasants getting burning torches and
going and burning down to whatever's around the medieval castle in terms of
senses of the word justice,
applying to what biology has to do with behavior.
There's so few people that share this idea that you're having,
obviously your sense of it is so much more educated and the average person and
you understand all the mechanisms behind all of these particular behavioral
problems that people have and all these different things can affect the way
human beings operate,
but most people are not aware of this.
I mean literally most people like if you had a guest,
if it's.
It might be in the 90 percent of people haven't really considered all the
factors that lead to someone having a brain that would put them in these
impulsive decision.
Terrible decision making situations.
Well,
what's what gives me a little bit of sort of optimism is most people though,
at least in the West,
have done that in a couple of realms like 500 years ago.
If you had an epileptic seizure,
the smartest,
most reflective,
most compassionate,
like middle ages,
bleeding heart liberals even would have had an explanation for what caused an
epileptic seizure,
which is you were demonically possessed and the therapeutic intervention whiston
Bernie with the steak,
and now instead we're are a century or two into having a mindset where instead
we make a biological statement,
Oh,
it's not him,
it's his disease.
Oh,
he's not demonically possessed these guts.
Something screwy with potassium channels in his brain,
unless he gets synchronized outbursts.
Every now and then he has a seizure disorder like it's taken us about 500 years
to do that one to go from.
This is a,
a blast from this behavior where we know the intervention,
which is to burn somebody at the state the same,
oh,
it's a biological problem and we even recognize constraints with it.
If somebody has uncontrolled epilepsy that's treatment resistant,
they may not be able to get a driver's license,
but you don't sit there and say,
yeah,
let's have a burning of the trivers licenses and the epileptics.
It's about damn time they got,
but they were.
No,
it's a realm where words like evil or soul or punishment or justice,
it's totally irrelevant.
Oh,
it's a neurological disorder.
So it's only taken us about 500 years to get to that point.
So maybe you know,
we've done that cognitive leap at least once.
Shit is going through under the city.
Every minute.
Comedy store has a bathroom,
there's a new bathroom.
They just put it in.
It backed up last night.
They have old pipes and a new bathroom.
I don't know what they did if they replace the pipes,
but something went wrong and I walked by the bathroom last night.
I was like,
what the fuck is that
about the smell of shit outside of the water.
That is just so.
So Chris,
back to the dog thing.
This is my.
We were talking about our dogs like rolling and shit and stuff.
My cousin doug the other day,
they had people coming to paint the house and my cousin's wife told them,
hey listen,
you can use our bathroom.
Don't worry about go.
You know,
you don't have to go outside.
He just,
our bathroom is your bathroom.
But they didn't really speak English,
they didn't really listen to her and some guy took a dump in the bushes.
The dog
rolled around.
He came running inside and she's like,
what is?
Oh my God,
how did you get human shit on your head?
How she knows it smelled different.
And then they went outside and looked and they're like,
you guys use our bathroom.
Oh,
sorry.
Oh No.
Oh my God.
Look what I found.
These guys are great.
Have you seen these guys that sat there?
So great.
Why does a dog water rolling?
Shit?
No.
What is that?
I don't know what possesses it to think that.
That's a good move.
Just so happy.
Oh Man.
I guess a role in this.
No one's going to throw a ball.
Oh,
rolling.
Damn.
Look what I found.
Have you met these guys?
They're awesome.
They're shit.
Smells terrific.